pushback against president Trump's
potential timeline for reopening this
country the president could unveil his
administration's strategy later today
beginning with areas that have the
smallest number of infections yeah
that's right mr. Trump wants to reopen
parts of the economy before the end of
this month but some business leaders are
balking at that timeline and the
president's own health officials say the
country still needs more testing Paula
Reid is at the White House for us again
Paula good morning what do we expect
from today good morning Tony the
president insists that we have passed
the peak of this outbreak but that is
much more optimistic language than his
medical experts are willing to use they
say mitigation is working but that we
need more testing before we can begin to
reopen parts of the country but later
today the president will have a call
with 50 state governors and he is
expected to encourage a handful of
states to begin to ease social
distancing governor's are looking for
that chomping at the bit to get going
the day after the highest us death toll
President Trump said it will soon be
time for parts of the country to reopen
they'll be safe they'll be strong but we
want to get our country back the White
House hinted that it may start in nine
states each with under a thousand cases
of coronavirus but on a call with the
president's new economic advisory groups
business leaders stressed the need for
more testing before they feel
comfortable reopening many governors and
public health experts agree including
dr. Anthony Falchi in an interview with
CBS News the success or failure of that
rolling reentry program as I call it
would be the capability of being able to
test identify isolate get someone who's
infected out of circulation amidst the
pandemic the president waded into a new
political fight threatening to adjourn
Congress so that he could push through
nominees for vacant government positions
I will exercise my constitutional
authority to adjourn both chambers of
Congress that constitutional power has
never been used and Democrats said it
was yet another way to divert
attention from what they called his
filled response to this outbreak it's a
distraction he's doing this as a way to
distract us from the topic at hand the
Constitution does not grant the
president the absolute power to adjourn
Congress only the authority to step in
if the House and Senate cannot agree to
do it themselves which is not the case
here the president conceded yesterday
that a move like this would likely face
legal challenges Gail Paula thank you